la coalition avenir québec promet
d'alléger le fardeau fiscal des
québécois un gouvernement de la
coalition avenir québec va remettre
mille dollars dans le portefeuille des
familles québécoises et cette somme va
aller directement aux familles en
abolissant la taxe santé et la taxe
scolaire
la caq promet une réduction de taxes
2000 $ par famille il s'agit d'une
moyenne car tous les québécois ne
profiterait pas de la même manière de la
réduction taxe proposée par la coalition
avenir québec
l'allégement fiscal proposée par la caq
repose essentiellement sur l'abolition
de la taxe scolaire
le montant versé en taxes scolaires
varient en fonction de la valeur
foncière d'une propriété le compte de
taxes d'une résidence cossue est
nécessairement plus élevé que celui d'un
simple bangolo en banlieue bref plus
votre maison vos chères plus votre
compte de taxes scolaires est élevé plus
le plan de la caq serait avantageux mais
qu'en est il des locataires au québec 39
% des ménages sont employés et il est
loin d'être certain que les
propriétaires profiterait de l'abolition
de la taxe scolaire pour baisser le coût
des loyers
les locataires pourraient profiter
néanmoins indirectement de l'abolition
de la taxe scolaire
si le fardeau fiscal des propriétaires
d'immeubles diminue la régie du logement
devraient techniquement limité la hausse
des loyers